Performance engineering isn't just about
making things fast, memory efficient, or
anything else. It's about this really
good feedback loop where you build
data-driven decisions to make your
codebase better.
>> It's so crazy. It's like one late night
prompt is the difference between good
and bad.
>> One line of code. You have to read lines
extremely carefully. I actually find
performance engineering is a great way
to like force yourself to read stuff
because everything is measurable, so you
can actually [music] like become better
at agentic engineering. All right, hello
everyone. Today we're going to go talk a
little bit about performance engineering
and show exactly how we're going to go
and make this
make it possible to leverage Claude and
other AI tools to make your systems a
lot faster. We go into two things. We go
into how we make strings faster in the
BAML VM. If you don't know what VM is,
it's a virtual machine very similar to
pi how Python and JavaScript run your
code on any host environment. We do the
same thing here.
And then the other thing we'll go into
is how we build a profiler and kind of
the approaches that we have and like the
level of detail that you need. Hopefully
by the end of it you're motivated enough
to go and try performance engineering on
your own and we give a little a few tips
on how you can go do that as well.
Check it out. How's everyone doing
today?
Make sure that's you specifically cuz no
one else can talk.
>> Oh, cuz the chat can't talk. I was like
waiting for you to read in the chat. All
right, we're going to assume everybody
in the chat is doing freaking great.
I'm doing great.
I just had a video crew in here for like
10 hours, 12 hours, 10 hours yesterday.
Um
it was it was a good time.
We're getting ready to do a very fun fun
launch soon, so uh
>> I'm excited.
>> to be great. But I didn't get to write
any code and I'm really excited to write
code all day today. And so I figured
what better way to warm up than learn
from one of the greats. Vaibhav, you
want to tell us what we're doing today?
>> Yeah, today is going to be a fun little
episode called no vibes allowed.
Every month or so or like four to six
weeks we do an episode where we just
like code together for a bit. We We chat
about our best practices, how we how we
do things on our team, how we do things
on your team, and just like trade notes.
Uh one of my favorite sessions here is
like always to just swap notes with
Dexter because I always learn something
new different from what he's doing.
Today, I wanted to share something that
is
probably very different than what most
people do with cloud code, which is high
performance engineering. Like how do you
make stuff really freaking fast?
>> Okay.
>> And I think there's all this stuff going
on with Bun doing all their ports like
Rust, and they make their like sizes
smaller for their binary, and they do
um they make their code faster, and they
make like image processing better. And
like how do they actually do this?
Turns out we do a lot of this work on
our team, too. So, I figured why not
just share some of the practices and how
we go about this and like where
where AI is good, where AI is not good,
and how you actually have to like catch
some of these contexts around.
>> Ooh, I feel like we're in for some uh
some back pressure today.
>> I have got a lot of back pressure.
>> Yeah.
>> I've also got tons of content that I've
actually already kind of been working
on, so
uh
I actually have like real work to share
with everyone about how we go do this
and just like how in-depth it gets cuz
it gets
performance engineering is one of the
few things that you cannot fake. There's
no metric that you can be like you're
slightly better. It's pure numbers. It's
totally unfakeable, so you just have to
do it right.
>> Amazing.
>> The hard part here is AI is actually
incredibly bad
at making really good performance
engineering decisions by default, and
that's because performance engineering
is inherently
the act of doing things that are usually
dangerous and not very safe
uh to get like the last ounce of
performance.
>> Ah, okay.
>> Yeah, and when you do that, the model
will do things that is like it's fast,
it's consistent. Um and it will do them
in like in reality, they don't work. Um
so, I want to share some of that context
today.
>> Amazing. And this is bringing me back a
little bit to uh the like performance
engineering in C class that I probably
took in undergrad a decade ago
of like random like I mean I'm sure
there's a bunch of naive techniques like
oh let's unroll the for loop into like
eight eight like blocks of eight or
whatever it is or let's to avoid like
the instruction pointer changes and
things like this but I'm sure we're
going to do something much more
sophisticated than that today. I can't
wait to see it. I did drop a new
whiteboard that is not shared with
everybody into the chat if you want to
use that one.
There we go.
>> Let's do it.
>> I don't know if we're whiteboarding or
if we're jumping straight to code today
though.
>> I'll do a little bit of whiteboard just
cuz it helps people have the context for
like how we go do this.
>> Cool.
>> So first things first
like what are we performance optimizing?
One of the things that we have in our
code base is a I'm going to move this
whiteboard here.
One of the things we have is basically a
virtual machine. A virtual machine is a
thing that takes in like assembly
equivalent of assembly
and basically says like
it does like fetch if you've ever taken
an operating systems class
decode
>> you by the way how did you get your
Excalidraw color scheme to be literally
the worst color combo in history of
orange
>> Oh I don't know what's happening.
>> I'm changing it to black because I can't
I can't look at that.
>> Okay, I fixed it.
Clearly I don't make a diagrams.
Fetch execute decode it's kind of like
the way to think about this and I guess
there's like a store instruction here.
Um
and like this is basically what every
computer does whenever it's executing
instructions. It looks at the
instruction figures out which
instruction it first gets the
instruction is it. Are you trying to do
like an add? Are you trying to do like a
move where you're moving a variable from
one to another? Are you doing a
Are you doing a store where you're
saving stuff to memory or loading stuff
from memory? Executing is doing the
actual execution so like if you're
adding two variables together the
execution is a part that actually adds
the two variables together.
And then a store is when you actually
save the computer result back to memory.
Going to do this. If you have a right
Python code, you have right JavaScript
code, or you have right Java code, this
is really the operation that's happening
under the hood to go do this stuff and
like make make it work across virtual
memory, make it work across different
operating systems, etc. The JVM does
something similar as well.
>> So for store in this case, would that be
like a store it back to a register, or
is this like cuz so this is like
executing a single instruction,
basically?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. But so this depends.
Are you running a virtual machine, are
you running like a actual machine? If
you're running a virtual machine, then
it's storing into memory in some model
of a register or equivalent of there's
like register VM, stack VMs, whatever.
Uh if you're running assembly
instructions, it actually saves it to
like physical memory. Or technically
virtual memory, but like you get the
point. There's
you don't actually have access to
physical page table
physical pages unless you really want
to.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um so this is kind of how you can
think about this operation stuff.
Um now, the problem is I'm sure as you
can tell, our computers are only your
programs will only ever be as fast as
this system is.
So if any of these things are very slow,
your system will be slow.
Now, for those of you that don't know,
uh in performance engineering, there's
basically three things you have to care
about.
Caches.
You want your cache to be good.
So like
Do
we
I'll hear. Use
more caches.
>> Do you have the concept of L1, L2, L3 in
your VM, or is that like kind of
>> that's a hardware construct.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> There's basically a couple things.
There's basically like use more caches,
do less work.
All right. Um
trying to remember the third one, but I
can't. Uh I'll remember at some point.
But there's basically these three things
that you going to optimize for and
there's nothing else that you can really
um
really uh really do in a better way.
And if you don't do one of these three
things, your code will not be faster.
Um the Oh.
Oh, yeah. I I guess technically it's
like this one.
This is kind of related to caches, but
it's slightly different. But it's like
effectively it's like use less things on
the heap. The more things you have on
the heap, the worse it is.
Um so, if you don't do these things,
your code will basically just be slow.
And if you do these things, your code
can only be as fast as these things are
fast effectively.
So, when we think about how to do
performance engineering any sort of run
time, any sort of stuff, the first thing
you have to do is actually measure. So,
we talked about back pressure, so you
build measurements. So, let's look at
how we do measurements really fast.
Where is this? I need This is a nice
little Claude code thing I've been
trying. But where is the other one?
I just need a terminal.
>> Oh, I see these guys on Twitter all the
time.
>> I've Yeah, it's a new little UI. I don't
mind trying new UIs and I learn
something interesting every time I try
something.
I do like the fact that I can see
>> and session grouping and they have the
file tree. Can you actually open files?
>> Um I I you can open files and that's
pretty nice. Oh, you guys will see the
actual the actual design docs all only
live in one place cuz there's I cannot
build the good design docs anywhere
else.
Um but um Claude Claude is still useful
for like various things. Like the things
that I'm about to do is definitely
useful.
So, like one of the things that we have
is these benchmarks that
>> Do it.
>> These benchmarks take a while to run, so
I just want to pull them up.
Um
So, one of the things that we have is we
actually have a script
that's only purpose
Control O.
That's only purpose is actually to help
benchmark.
Um BAML against like all sorts of
things. We BAML We benchmark BAML
against our own baseline relative
itself. We benchmark BAML against
Python. We benchmark BAML against Node.
We benchmark BAML against Bun. We
actually built a lot of tooling.
>> so this table is readable, dude? Sorry.
>> Let me find you another version of this
table that is actually readable.
I run This is all I've been doing for
the last few days.
Uh
And if I can't, I will just rerun this
table again because I know what command
it is.
And then this is in
What is a PWD?
Man, the problem with all these systems
is finding like stuff like the PWD is
very hard. Copy path, okay.
And then we'll go here.
All right. And then we'll just run this.
And this should probably do some stuff.
Okay. This will run some stuff behind
the scenes and it'll show some
benchmarks.
Uh but we actually spent some time real
time building some tooling that actually
does this and I'll show you what this
tooling does.
>> I was going to say what what are we
benchmarking? You say benchmark BAML
against a bunch of other languages. What
what are we benchmarking? Is this like
Oh, it's fit fit Fibonacci. Okay, cool.
>> So, it's actually not just Fibonacci.
And this is the amazing part about all
these stuff.
We actually have a bunch of workloads
that we've defined.
So, like there's workloads like
Fibonacci recursive. So, we're like it
let's try Fibonacci in the recursive
pattern. And this checks how expensive
it is is it to call functions inside of
BAML.
There's benchmarks against calling
Fibonacci in an in a
What This
There's like the pi And then we have the
Python equivalent, we have the bam
equivalent, and we have the TypeScript
equivalent for all of them.
Then we have the iterative version of
Fibonacci. Let's go calculate how
expensive that is.
>> like tail recursion or whatever.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> doesn't have tail recursion, right?
>> Yeah, it just does like temporary. What
do you mean by tail recursion?
>> Of like where you when you do the
recursive call, it can basically like
replace instead of like creating a new
stack frame, it can just replace the
current stack frame.
>> Oh, I see.
>> Like an optimization that you can do in
like C and languages like that. I don't
think Python supports it.
>> interesting.
Um interesting.
Um so you can do stuff here. Uh we just
measure this. We measure all sorts of
things like what is it like to traverse
a binary tree, what is it like to to
like a nested for loop with like various
counters.
We basically just came up like what
happens with closures.
Do clo- Are closures expensive? Are
variable captures? If, else, and a whole
bunch of other scenarios.
Uh and you just go and measure every
single thing you want to go measure, and
that tells you how expensive things are.
And if you don't
>> memory usage? Are you measuring timing?
Are you measuring
>> Timing.
>> What are you measuring here?
>> Timing is the main thing we measure
right now. We're not We don't care about
optimizing for memory, though we're
pretty good. But we do measure timing.
>> And in general, I have lots of memory.
If you can make it run faster and use
more memory, I would rather have it be
fast.
>> Yeah, exactly. So we're basically
measuring timing right now. We will
eventually measure memory. We measure
binary size and stuff, too, but we're
pretty good on binary size. So I don't
really It's not a thing that we're
optimizing for.
But once you've measured that,
if you don't actually spend the time to
build that sort of system in place where
you're actually measuring stuff, you
basically will end up with a loop that
has no usage. And one of the things that
I I ran into, and this is what part of
what this PR fixes, is
we didn't have standard deviations here.
And if you don't have standard
deviations, then you can't possibly
measure exactly how much noise you have
in your system, and then and can't tell
where the actual difference is relative
to anything else. And that's really
important to go spend time doing.
So, we just had to go do that. We had to
add like a standard deviation in there.
And you can you'll probably notice that
like Bammel has various standard
deviations built into it.
Um but this is just like a small little
script that we built and as soon as the
results come out, we can actually go
into the details of like one one of the
performance optimizations we did and how
much effort it took to make this
actually work.
I'll give you guys a teaser while this
is running cuz
the hardest part about performance
benchmarks and what I'm currently
struggling with with Claude
is just how long it takes
to actually run them.
Um and then Claude's iteration loop just
like
completely dies. And the thing is you
can't even run them in parallel because
if you run them in parallel,
you actually affect the CPU in the
profiling.
So, you can't actually do any of this
stuff in parallel as well. So, it's kind
of a pain in the ass.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah, so you have to run
everything in sequence because you don't
want them competing for resources on
your machine and that impacts the actual
like end-to-end wall time.
>> Exactly.
And like right over here, for example,
like you can see like our function
dispatch is extremely expensive. So,
we're working on making this faster. The
things I worked on were like
string-related stuff right now. So, it's
really fast we made strings extremely
fast in Bammel.
Um but what's been really interesting is
I want to show you kind of the process
of how long it takes to make something
better.
Uh similar use case would be like a SQL
query optimization. Exactly. If you want
to do a SQL query optimization, you kind
of need to do the same thing.
Um and if you were going to do a SQL
query optimization, you'd build the same
thing. You'd build some sort of
benchmark suite that actually
understands the workload. I call these
workloads.
That understands the workload of what
you're doing.
Um and then once you understand the
workload what you're doing, you can
actually just
build a short little script that
actually puts a summary table down below
like this.
And then what's interesting is Claude
code has learned to basically only
capture this by searching for a vertical
bar.
It grabs for vertical bar, finds this
table, and then just gives me a summary
of the actual impact.
But, it's really useful that we actually
just capture this data. One of the
mistakes that I learned, and I've I
learned this more and more as I do
performance engineering,
is I wish we had originally saved all
this stuff to JSON all the time by
default. So, now we just save this to
JSON all the time by default.
And that way, if Claude needs to re-get
some of the data,
it actually just gets the data instead
of having to um rerun the whole
benchmark, which as you saw, took like
at least like 2 minutes or 3 minutes,
maybe longer, to actually go run this
all the way through.
Um so, that's been uh that was like a
really quick, easy learning. Like,
serialize your performance benchmarks as
much as possible, as much so you can
like quickly refer to them one at a
time.
But, I want to show you how long the
process actually took. So, one of the
things I did is I made strings way
faster in BAML.
Um as a part of making strings faster in
BAML, where's the speed
>> Yeah, do you have the before and after
result, or is this just compared to
other languages?
>> Uh I have before and after, too. There's
a baseline thing in here.
Here, I I will ask Claude to describe to
me how much faster I made this.
Claude.
>> So, baseline is the BAML baseline?
>> Explain
the impact.
Baseline is against like our main
branch, effectively.
Like, baseline is what the main branch
is, and then the non-baseline
>> Exactly. The BAML is the uh
non-baseline.
So, I'll give you the baseline. But,
while we do this, I want to show you
kind of how we did this and like what
the research requirement is to make
strings faster.
Uh
Why can I
open
I can't open
>> to archive task extra?
>> Open archive task.
>> You should command K.
>> I'll try again. It was not clicking
through.
That's the first time I've ever seen
>> to use my product on stream, you you
have to only use it when it's working.
You can't use it when it's bugged.
[laughter]
>> I got our code task. So, one of the
things I was working on is
where's the strings one?
What is this organized by recency?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, maybe strings is like that.
>> If you hit command K, I think it will
search all sessions.
>> Okay, what is going on here? Um I put
together I want to show you this ticket
of what kind of ticket I got.
So, basically I did a whole bunch of
work with cloud code to just
independently research how strings work.
And when I did strings work, I basically
I'll show you how strings perform and
like why strings are slow in general.
Um
And so, for example, one of the things I
was able to do with this current work is
I made strings roughly six times faster
um in like concat use cases. And
obviously, if you concat less things,
it's like three times faster. But so,
basically it scales
uh as you keep uh stacking strings
because we reduce memory allocations.
And like building short strings is about
two times faster. So, basically like
effectively like almost twice as fast as
um Python.
In the case of making our strings uh
in the case of our like how good strings
are in BAML.
>> Is this specifically like concatenating
strings?
>> And allocating strings and like building
strings and a few other things in here.
But basically like the usage of strings.
Why do we do this? Well, because like if
you're in a language that's Well, if
you're going to use a lot of strings in
your language cuz you have a lot of
prompts, you have large strings, you
have slices, you have all these other
things out here. I've also made slices
>> like token chunks and all this kind of
stuff, right?
>> Exactly. And I've made like slices in
BAML much faster, too. I don't have a I
don't have a workload for this, but I'll
produce that in a second. Make a
workload
that will show how much better
slicing parts of a large string is.
And cool.
They'll go do that.
Um so, when we made slicing everything
better, how do we do this? Well, I
didn't I I mean, I had some ideas. The
reason strings were expensive is because
we were allocating a whole chunk of
memory the whole time through. And
remember, rule number one, allocate less
memory. Um and that's use the heap less.
So, when we did this, all I really did
was I told Claude to go research this.
And then, even though I have ideas and I
have biases, I actually try my best not
to bring them in. And instead, what I
have Claude do is I have Claude go
research a couple of things. Go research
every possible optimization crate in
Rust, because I'm not while I do write a
lot of Rust, I don't know everything in
Rust. I don't know every crate that
people already used. So, I had to go do
that.
I had to go understand the memory layout
of everything.
And understand the clone cost. I had to
understand the worst parts, the worst
offenders of strings in the Rust code
base.
I had to go understand like where we're
allocating too much memory that we don't
actually need.
And where we're holding onto memory. And
then, I had it go allocate I had it go
research exactly how V8
and uh it's somewhere in here.
I had to go research exactly how V8 and
Python both do string optimizations. And
for that, I have a
special thing where I have
LS
repos/CPython.
And I literally have the entire Python
library code base just downloaded onto
here. And then, I have the same thing.
>> Oh, amazing.
>> repos/V8.
And I have the entire V8 repo down here.
So, even though V8 is well documented,
even though CPython are well documented,
nothing is better than the source of
truth. So, literally just spinning up
research has to go understand exactly
how they work. Just saves me so much
time
that I don't even have to make
decisions. I don't really have to learn,
and then all I have to do is go
understand what are the trade-offs that
it's going to make.
And then once it does this, I basically
have Claude put together a giant table
of all the possible things that we
should do. And I also had to go
listen to Lua, because Lua is actually a
pretty interesting language in terms of
how it does optimizations.
And then I actually just let it run
through the
what's RPI process. And once I did the
RPI process, I did the next thing. I
spent a lot of time in design.
You know what this is?
>> Chat boxes. If you've ever seen me go do
stuff
on here, my design stage is super long.
And the reason the design stage is super
long is
I'll show you what it does.
I found some bugs in here.
Is I realized that some of the stuff
that it's actually doing is actually not
actually
perfect.
And specifically one of the mistakes
that it made was it was trying to change
how maps work in BAML to accommodate for
how
um for how like V8 does certain things,
and we didn't want to go do that.
So I had to go actually undo that and
catch that around. There's a couple and
that changed performance criteria. We
also have threading, and neither V8 nor
Python actually have true threading.
They Python uses the GIL, and V8 uses
like a single event loop on a single
worker.
>> Yep.
>> So we don't have we have slightly
different constraints that they kind of
have to work on.
And one of the And once you go down this
loop though, it actually is really easy
to have a model make some amount of
decisions
fairly I want to go show some of the
decisions that are actually useful.
To make most kinds of decisions fairly
automatically
without really being included uh in the
loop as a human.
Cuz what I have is I have a
Good.
>> Sorry, keep keep keep going. I have I
have this is I have an interesting
thought here.
>> Yeah. The main things that Remember,
because I know the principles, useless
memory,
like use better caches, all I do is I
just try and in uh uh instantiate
principles into here and like because
this is super sensitive work, I actually
do read every line of like code snippet
that Sand Dog has.
And one of the early things that has is
heart starting to hardcode variables.
If it hardcodes variables, that means
it's going to screw up later down the
line. Because if the number 70 isn't
correct, I need to change it to like 56.
Cloud will technically do that, but if
it misses one, then my performance
characteristics downstream are going to
be messed up and then during
implementation of verification, the
agent will not work.
>> So you actually designing the code
changes or you also I'm curious like cuz
my my mental model of how this might
work is sort of like, "Hey, here's a
bunch of approaches we could try."
Um, and I don't know what the actual
like correct approach is because we have
to kind of benchmark against it to see.
Are you relying on the model having
actually like an understanding like
of the exact inner workings of the VM or
are you like There's two ways you could
do this. You could do the design
discussion and you could design exactly
what you want to do
uh and then you could tell the model to
go build it or you could
design like the criteria and the
feedback loop and then include a bunch
of like things to try and then your
implementation becomes a little less of
like, "Hey, here's a specific list of
things that we're going to go do." and
it becomes a little more of like, "Hey,
cool. Here's how you're going to know if
it's working. Here's 30 different like
dimensions along which to experiment."
>> I I To be completely honest, I don't
think there's like 30 different
dimensions on which to experiment. Most
things.
>> But I don't I don't even think there are
that many. Like most things have a
well-defined problem. Very, very few
things are truly novel and require um
Of all the three that I recommended,
this one
uh
There's like there's like a secret one
here that like very few times comes up,
which is like
do different work.
>> Right. That's the novel one. That's like
the inverse square root kind of thing,
right?
>> Yeah, like you you can do this. Uh but
this is just so rare in my experience.
We've done this a couple times.
But it's just so rare that I don't
usually bring this up. And most stuff in
performance engineering can be
researched.
>> Should we talk about the fast inverse
square root as an example of that or do
you want to just do concretely like what
you did?
>> Well, we can talk about that in a
second. Uh I want to share like examples
of like the techniques that we found
very useful. So like I think if someone
is going to do some of this stuff, what
I would recommend is like if you know
how you're going to go measure this,
what I would personally do is if I have
three different ideas, like what you're
suggesting Dexter, I would actually do
three different design design
discussions.
I would spin up three different
workspaces, three different tasks that
are not polluted with each other, and
maybe have some shared context. But I
should do the complete three completely
different design discussions and spin up
three different work trees that all
build all of them.
But remember, you can't actually run all
of them in parallel on your machines
because you have to be careful about
what workloads you're running on your
machine to actually profile this.
>> Yep.
>> The best thing you can actually do to
profile is have dedicated hardware that
you're running profile tests on. That's
what we should really do.
And I'll show you my next task of why
we're doing this in a second.
But it really the trick here is like you
have to be super detail-oriented. You
actually have to go uh there's like a
bug that the LLVM made somewhere in
here.
Uh
and like I mean it was like one sentence
of a bug that changed what data
structure I was going to use, whether it
was going to be like like a locked or an
atomic.
And because of that single bug would
have changed exactly how um
the exactly how
uh how efficient it would have been.
And if we didn't do that correctly Oh
wait, here we go. There's like another
bug that we have.
Um like for example, one of the things
that we had here was if you think about
like the memory layout, we have like an
object type and the actual string type.
And the amount of memory that our object
type was taking
was I think like 70 bytes or something.
And our string Go ahead.
>> I was going to say, can can you draw
some of this? Like your your conceptual
um
>> Let me just pull up the code. It might
be easier.
>> Okay.
Also, I don't know. There's a There's a
There's a new feature I can show you,
which is like uh using HTML mock-ups
inline to like
>> Oh, zoom
in.
>> Um yeah, let's try it.
So, I mean, uh you can go to this
conversation if you have some context.
>> I have all the context here.
>> Yeah, it's like, "Hey, can you
>> But, I want to
>> Yeah.
>> Is this forking now?
>> Uh yes, you're forking from that last
user message there.
>> Can you draw what user make a
>> I'll just do this. It's fine. Can you
draw how
uh Bexter works? It's memory layout.
>> I'll give you a magic word.
>> Okay.
>> Uh use an inline HTML mock-up.
>> That cool. I'll do that.
>> Oh, so it can actually So, it can
actually do like we we
We'll We'll see how this works. We're
still tuning the actual like how do you
get it to do the thing and
>> How does it decide when to do the thing?
Um but there's a syntax that it can send
in assistant messages that is like
display an HTML image in the in the
actual stream.
>> That's cool. Okay, well, we'll see if it
if it does that. Um but while it pulls
that up
somewhere in here I have like Bexter or
something.
>> Yeah.
Bexter
>> hard to find code. I don't even know how
to find code in here.
>> Command P.
>> And then because this thing doesn't have
an L speed, it's very annoying.
Oh, there we go. Okay.
Um so one of the things that we do in
strings, so again, remember, you want to
leave use this memory hit the cache
more. So our strings are now like single
allocated immutable strings.
What that means is in languages like uh
Rust, one of the things that you can do
in your strings is you can write
something like
like
let's
let my string
and this is not real Rust code, ABC, and
then you can do my string
0 equals A.
This is like a thing you're not allowed
to do. Strings are allowed to be mutable
and they don't work. In Python and
JavaScript and like most um
interpreted languages, you actually
can't do this. Strings become immutable.
And what happens when you actually go do
when you do like a dot concat,
uh
is you actually produce a new string
here rather than allocating to that
existing string's memory in place.
So you're not referencing the same
thing, you're actually just producing a
new string.
>> Right.
>> One of the things that we do here is and
similarly when you do a slice, my string
>> the pointer to point to the new object,
basically.
>> Yeah. Like if you do a slice of the
string, let's say like this goes on for
like like 100 more characters,
if you like the first five characters of
the string,
now what this means is if this is
immutable, instead of actually copying
the string and copying the first five
characters over,
you can actually just
say, "Nope, we'll just remember the
number of how many characters we have
and keep the same pointer, so we're only
we're really not duplicating the string
over and over again."
>> This is very like C-like, right? Where
you just you store it as like the
pointer to the wherever the first
character is in memory and then and know
the length.
>> Exactly. So this is actually actually
exactly how uh
V8 and Python all work.
But again, once I did the research and I
was able to go confirm all this, then we
basically just went through and were
able to say, "Okay, well, there's a nice
little optimization we can do, which is
for strings that are super short, we
actually don't allocate them on the
heap, we just allocate them onto a stack
with whatever capacity we have left in
this array."
For strings that are big, they're like
heap allocated. For slices,
they point to an original string, but
then they tell us exactly what the
offset and the length of the slices. So,
it kind of looks like a slice.
Uh and then we also keep a hash around.
We'll talk about why we keep the hash
around. Concatenation is kind of
similar. Instead of actually
concatenating a string at any given
time,
what we actually do is we just say a
concatenation is just a thing that
points to two different strings.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> then and then at any point if you ever
access them, then we'll convert it from
a like a writable access,
then we'll convert it from a deferred
string to an to an actual allocated
string.
>> Fascinating.
>> And then did you get this from V8 or
Python or is this like an old
>> this
V8 also does this, but not as nicely
because we're in in C. We're running in
Rust, so we can do something a lot less
a little bit more performance
and not not.
>> Nice.
>> And then the hash trick was actually
something that I just directly copied
from V8. That was really clever. So,
strings are expensive to hash,
especially big strings, it becomes an
O(n) operation. If you store the hash,
that's only after usage, it becomes an
O(1) operation.
So, it's just really convenient to go do
this. So, you get like a lazy hash.
>> This is using more caches.
>> This is using more caches. Well,
>> And hash is really useful cuz you need
it to build as like if you're using
strings as map keys, you need you need
that hash.
>> Yeah, exactly. If you want to do like
string comparison, the hash is a great
comparison mechanism. It's like it's
basically like a really fast way to do
all sorts of things on strings and in a
language in a world where we use prompts
as all sorts of things, every single
microsecond counts.
So, you get like just way faster
speed-ups.
>> On that I don't think that
>> worked.
Did it work?
>> I put another prompt in the chat that
you should grab instead.
In the public chat.
>> Okay.
So, hopefully this kind of helps explain
kind of like what the
what the trade-offs here are and how we
did performance optimization for
strings. Basically, build a really good
data set and build really good
representative workloads.
Build a quick eval suite that systems
can run on.
Understand that you can't actually like
multitask performance unless you have
dedicated hardware.
Um and then
then just read really, really carefully
and keep on asking Claude to explain
other state-of-the-art that is already
doing certain things so you don't have
to reinvent everything on the fly and
you have Claude as a really good
reference example behind the scenes.
So, that's basically the TLDR. Now, I
think there's another thing while this
is running.
>> Yep.
>> That's worth thinking about. So, once I
did this
the next thing I realized is holy cow,
this is not going to work.
So, we actually just want to build a
profiler
um into the language itself.
>> So, you don't have to like run these
slow ass like black box benchmarks.
>> Exactly. Cuz if I can build a profiler
into the language itself, then I can go
do this. So, again, how did I go do
this? I didn't actually build a
profiler. I This is again comes from
like a background Claude discussion that
I had that took like an hour and a half.
I had to go look at my existing
architecture and actually like draw
things out to go explain things.
And then I basically just told it it's
like the rules are I want to have zero
allocations.
Like I basically don't want to have any
allocations that are ever happening
unless I really need to and I to
serialize things.
>> Inside the inside the profiler itself?
>> Exactly.
I want to have no overhead when I'm
disabling this. Effectively no overhead.
Like I'm okay with like half a
nanosecond, but effectively no overhead.
Um I want to make sure that like nothing
is ever in the hot path is ever being
blocked. And then I want to make sure
that like no um
yeah, we don't have like a limit of like
how much of a stack depth we want to be
able to track infinite call stacks all
the way through it. And it's we want it
to still be fast.
And then I
I did all of this uh and I did a lot of
research here ahead of time.
Then even after this, where's my ticket?
Oops.
There's one more ticket that I Oh, this
is actually comes from a separate work
item. Let me open this.
After all this work, I had a This is a
much shallower ticket. I I left a note
for it. I have a CPython and V8
available in these places.
So then I made it do a bunch of
research.
Um and and there's initial research
actually for whatever reason refused to
look at C8 and Python. So I made it stop
and I said, "Actually go look up V8 and
Python and go look up exactly what they
do."
After it did that,
uh it produced a design discussion.
Um and then after it produced a design
discussion, you'll notice this one is
really short
because I kind of wanted the research
prompt as my basis here because again
I'm doing a lot more research here than
I am actual work. So this is where it's
like a little bit fuzzy how you have to
use these AI tools.
So I went back to the research prompt
and I actually made it iterate with me
for a long time. I actually fed the
design doc into it
as an input.
And once I had enough context and enough
trust about the system,
and the model got a lot of things wrong
uh because this was even more sensitive
than the string work. There's not that
much work that replicates this.
Uh this is somewhat novel because what
is expensive
I'll give everyone
a quick little primer.
The way Python works is
Python basically says whenever you call
a function and you call the call
function instruction
you pass in a few parameters to it like
the function name and the args and
whatever. Function name, args,
etc.
And I'll show you something interesting
about what Python does.
When you actually call a function, it
actually replaces the call function
instruction at runtime with a
call function instrumented.
>> Huh.
>> And this thing is slow. So there's
basically
it doesn't wrap it. It's a totally
different instruction.
So there's like Python bytecode that's
kind of doing this stuff and like
there's a int fetch instruction that's
called call function.
When you set a thing that's like
the sys.set
uh tracing or something, set uh tra- I
forgot the exact name.
>> Yeah.
>> go do this, it finds your Python
bytecode that you wrote.
It saves it in a different memory
location. Says, "Hey, this function now
actually just this op code now points to
this op code instead."
So this is why Python tracing can give
you extremely rich detail, like exactly
what line of code you're running.
And every other ounce of detail on it.
But it also adds a 100x delay on how
much slower it is than the regular call
function.
>> Oh, no.
>> So it's extremely rich. But 100 times
slower.
So that's obviously bad for various
reasons.
Um JavaScript has a totally different
system. So this has extremely high
coverage and you can build really
interesting tooling on it, like what
line of code is slow in my code.
Uh in JavaScript's code base is actually
totally separate. JavaScript code base
and JavaScript is
like V8 is incredibly amazing beast cuz
it does things like jit and a whole
bunch of other stuff.
Actually it something else. Uh there's
also like some other trampoline stuff
that it does here to
help uh sysprofiles work.
What JavaScript says is, "Hey, instead
of actually doing this,
I'm just going to have a sample thread
that runs like at let's say one every 1
millisecond
and just probes at the call stack in a
really safe way and just like copies and
pastes it in a good way.
So, while this is extremely expensive,
this is much, much cheaper and they've
done a lot of memory optimizations to
not have to copy everything under the
hood. What this does mean though is in
practice you can miss some functions
that you might be calling and not have
really clear understanding of this.
Uh and again, both of these work for
various constraints, but the primary
constraint that both these come with is
that they're all single-threaded
systems.
And if you want to have extremely high
coverage while doing really good
profiling, you kind of need to be really
detailed. So, this is kind of where I
found that like handling that event
coming in loses a lot of context
because we're not a single-threaded
system.
So, in this workload I actually had no
choice
but to actually go incredibly deep and
just like have it actually like
uh I'll show you where where can I show
this?
I have some chat items.
Um
like for example, like it just this was
me typing it like 10 hours ago. So, like
at 12:56 I was slightly delirious when
I'm typing.
As you can tell over here.
Um but the cloud literally understands
it pretty well.
I literally have to be like, "Hey,
yeah, this is not even close." I
literally have to be like, "Oh, this is
this even going to work for virtual
threads?" Um it doesn't because
the data it's storing assumes like a
single thread.
>> Oops.
>> So, once it caught that it was like,
"Oh, yeah, it won't actually work for
this." And then it was like, "Oh, here's
the core difference." And it started
going to this. But like the key part
here is you don't actually have to know
all the details. You have to catch just
key things that are going to mess it up
completely.
>> Yeah, this is a really interesting like
you're demonstrating really interesting
concept that I'm like I've been trying
to
um
like articulate recently
which is like comes from the core of
like 12 factor agents and and all this
stuff which is like LLMs are really good
at turning
one type of data into another type of
data. Whether it's like a string user
message and turning it into structured
output for formatting whether it's
taking a bunch of information and
summarizing it down whether it's taking
a couple ideas and turning it in blowing
it up into a big slop shitty Twitter
article. Like whatever it is it's like
agents are just like data reformatters
and so in any prompt to an LLM you're
basically taking like the information
that's in the weights which for a
generic agent is like the entire
internet
plus the user's prompt and then it's
going to and maybe some like context
you're injecting like memories or rag or
whatever it is and it's going to
transform according to your prompt and
the input context and the weights is
going to like transform that into
something else. Whether it's structured
or unstructured whether it's a summary
or an expansion uh and I think we do the
same thing with coding agents. I use a
phrase like agents are basically code
rotators where you take the weights
which is the entire internet plus a
bunch of like information that is built
into it in the like sweet bench RL
torment nexus. So it's like basically
you take the entire internet and then
you take like Django and Redis and some
other really big code bases and then you
take your prompt and you take what code
did the agent find and then you wrote in
your code base. So it's like taking your
patterns or in your case you're taking
code from other VMs and other programs
and you're taking that and then you're
rotating it into fit into the target
place which is like code for your VM.
>> Yep. And like
models are phenomenal at this but
they're only going to be as good as like
the key decisions that you can make. So
like in a high-risk task like this one,
you just have to be able to find these
key things. Like I may not know
everything about how like
Rust async works all down to the
nitty-gritty of how Rust actually like
schedules like specific uh
like hardware instruction or like a some
instructions cuz like I just haven't
spent time on that yet. But I do know
roughly the fact that we're
multi-threaded. I know that we have
virtual threads and I know we're not
pinned to OS threads. So I need to make
sure the VM can actually recognize this
and go find out what it does. And once
it shows me this diagram,
I actually have really high confidence
that it understood the problem that we
have.
And once I understand this, it's like
great. I I may not even read everything
at the same time.
Um I'm even okay and then obviously like
Windows is a whole different ballgame.
That's like totally messed up for
different reasons.
Uh and same with WASM and everything
else. But I don't actually have to read
all this. I just kind of need to
understand this and really think
carefully about like how does it do
this? And once it does this,
I actually need to say
uh like right over here, I found another
thing.
I was like, oh. And this is like a
really subtle thing. And again, I'm
typing it like the middle of the night
so like my brain is uh very very
limited. Um but luckily I can do this
now. I used to not be able to code that
late, but now I can. And how did I know
this? Well, I looked at this code.
Uh not this one.
Uh
one of these codes. I looked at this
Where did it go?
I looked at one of these code snippets.
And like what I do is while it's
generating the next thing, I just looked
at this code and I was like, hey.
This thing is a pretty big array on the
stack. So that likely means that it's
going to be heap allocated. And every
time this is heap allocated,
uh that means that this is going to be
an expensive allocation. Because max
stack depth, like how big do you think a
stack can get? It's like 50,000
elements.
Like you don't want that on your stack
even if you do cuz it's going to blow
out every it's going to blow out your
whole cache even if you do this.
So what we need to be careful about is
like I don't think that this should be
allocated every single time I call this
function. This should be a single
allocation once for the lifetime of the
thread.
Like, this is a worker thread that comes
up every single time, so I should not
reallocate this again.
And this is just me staring at this. So,
once I decide that, while the while all
this stuff is happening, I just went
back and stared at it and I was like,
"Okay, cool. Let me just tell you that."
>> This is so crazy. It's like one like
>> one line of code
>> practically typed late-night prompt is
the difference between good and bad. And
it's like, "Okay, cool. So, like the AI
models are really good at certain
things." And I'm I'm just curious like,
if you weren't sitting there driving
this, what would have happened? Like,
would this have just ended up in a dead
end? Like
>> Yeah, cuz it would it would do all the
work and then I'd measure and I'm like,
"Oh, it's not faster." So, you can
actually do that with these pro
programs. You can't just be like, "Oh,
it's not faster." and say that's good
enough. You actually have to go ahead
and spend time like reading some of this
code when you're doing performance
engineering work.
And that's why like Jared, you'll notice
when he talks about like Bun and all the
stuff he does, he still reads a lot of
PRs.
It's because this stuff is super
sensitive to like data races. It's super
sensitive to like seg-faulting. It's
super sensitive to like not being
performant cuz of one line of code.
So, when we go
it did a bunch of work over here. And
then what's interesting is as it did all
this, it's so and like I literally like
And again, do I trust this?
Like, probably
is my intuition. But, the important part
is now that I've primed it to think
about allocations, I trust this.
And then I literally and then it starts
to research how V8 does it and I'm like,
"Great. Now I know what data sets it's
referring to and its context window when
it does this." So, I have again, higher
confidence that it's good, but not
perfect.
And then when it actually does this, I
do a
uh I do another thing and I'm like,
"Okay. Well, one of the mistakes that it
made was let's just track call stacks."
And it started tracking only 12 call
stacks in here.
Um there's somewhere in here. It was
like I'll only track I think it may it
made a content of this. I was like, oh
it will only track 12 call 12 frames
like 12 call stacks.
is two wins and like
if the stack is deeper than 12, truncate
it. I'm like, what? You can't just
truncate Like it just made a totally
incorrect assumption this one line. 12
is enough for 99% of animal stacks in
>> [laughter]
>> It's not enough. Like it
You know, I was just like You So you can
see how if you miss
>> my part.
>> You can see how if you miss something
really
really detailed in the work, it can make
something really foundationally
incorrect. And I think performance
engineering is one of the few places
where this stuff pops up really easily.
This happens in every single ounce of
software engineering with AI. It has one
or two sentences that are just subtly
wrong.
And most of the time it doesn't matter.
But I think that's why we see more and
more slop everywhere. And then in
performance and and I ship slop too. I'm
guilty of this too. But in performance
engineering, I'm like super mentally
aware.
Uh even though even though my brain is
clearly can't type correctly, but at
least I'm super mentally aware of
looking for certain things that I know
are problematic.
And then once I did this, I was like it
was like, yes, recursive JSON
serialization nested objects is easily
50 to 200 call stacks.
Like super trivially possible.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
So then I actually went through and did
the right thing. Good.
>> I'd be I'd be really interested to also
see the like HTML like drawing of like
draw me like a history of how this
design evolved over time.
>> Yeah, let's do it.
>> Um
And just you can use this like and show
it to me as a task artifact.
Yeah, how this design evolved over time.
Oops.
Alt over time.
Show Yeah.
>> Uh
>> Yep, exactly. Perfect.
>> I hope. And there's a lot of work I did
in here, but eventually you guys have
seen this technique before. What I do is
I'll often write I'll take all this
learnings and everything I have. I had
it separately research how V8 and
everything works and I started writing
tickets.
I started writing a whole new ticket
from scratch. As for my
>> Yep. ticket until I was pretty happy
with it.
And like this one is way more detailed,
but then I noticed like
firstly did some weird segmentation with
V1 V2. So then I was like that's
completely garbage. I want like a pure
ticket.
Uh and then it was like
>> You'll figure out the like slicing of
milestones later basically.
>> Exactly. I don't want to deal with this.
I want to do everything. And then I'm
had to go do all of this. Um
I had actually now it actually
summarized why V8 doesn't actually work,
what's problematic with it, etc. etc.
I had some architecture diagram, but
this even had some more problems.
So then eventually I actually I did
another set of conversations that I
actually built ticket for. And ticket
four is actually quite good.
Um and it it should I think lead to a
good actual work task. So then I took
this ticket.
>> And that was the seed for your next
task.
>> Uh we're actually like okay, now that I
have this ticket, now let's go ahead and
put together a real ticket to make it
actually work.
>> Let's Let's see if that one produced. I
think it did finish making the making
the visualization, right?
>> Oh, that's kind of cool.
>> so it looks like All right, let's see.
You can full screen this.
>> So yeah, this actually like this
probably a better description than
anything I did. This is really cool
texture.
>> I was going to say this is like instead
of making you Excalidraw the whole
thing, I'll bet Claude can draw it.
>> Yeah, exactly. And it will do a better
job. And you can This is kind of cool.
This actually It you exactly kind of the
differences we made.
Uh let me see if I can describe this.
And it shows you like the four types of
strings where like a string short
strings are basically allocated directly
in the stack. There's no heap
allocation.
Substring views are basically a parent
plus offset and um length over here.
Immutable strings are basically pointers
and they're ref counted all the way
down. So, clones are cheap.
And then concatenation strings are
either like
either they're a copy and paste of a
back string, so one of these four
variants, or they're actually allocated
right in place.
>> Yep.
>> And actually talks about like where the
performance winner happens as well,
which is kind of nice. This is actually
really cool.
>> Yeah. We've been doing this a lot. This
is also also like I know you don't do a
lot of UI work, but we're also using
these in a lot of places. It's like
instead of going and writing a bunch of
react like just like align visually with
me. Show me what we think the UI is
going to look like before we actually as
part of the design discussion.
>> This is actually really cool. Uh
this is actually really cool.
>> Yeah. We like this. This is uh yeah,
especially if you want to present this
to somebody else or something and you
have a ton of context baked into either
an implementation or results or a design
discussion. This could be a really
powerful way of like basically I mean
every the key to doing hard [__] with
LLMs is like how can you maximize your
alignment with the LLM? How can you
catch where it was wrong and how can you
basically like make sure that you're
doing the right kind of thinking without
you know
>> Yep.
>> Not everybody has the vibe of superpower
of staying up until 1:00 in the morning
reading C code until you figure it out.
>> Technically Rust. And like
>> Yeah, sure.
>> For example, like here's one of the cool
things that we did. We like uh for those
of you who know our JavaScript and is
famously um
known for like being incredibly fast
because of JIT. Like our string stuff is
now like just purely faster than even
like Bun's version of JIT.
We're like around
the 4 second 30% faster than like Bun's
version of JIT.
Which is for an interpreted language I
think quite hard to go do.
>> Yeah.
That's cool.
>> No.
Let's go back and like take a look at
this though. This I think is going to be
much more interesting.
Um
Let me see if I can find any interesting
visuals here that are actually worth
spinning off into.
>> I mean you could also ask it to iterate
on it and be like I want more boxes and
lines or like show me how the stack is
laid out or whatever.
>> Um let me see. I It's try Yeah, let me
do it.
Instead of using markdown visuals inside
of each of the things, can you please
just draw like actual React components
that connect together with boxes and
lines?
>> That's not React, but it's just HTML.
>> Yeah, there you go.
>> And that was boxes and lines.
>> Nice.
>> Yeah, cool. Uh it'll be way easier to
see.
But like honestly, this is kind of the
work that it comes to performance
engineering. You don't actually do any
of it. You just like sit You have to
read lines extremely carefully. If you
want to practice how to get better with
agents,
I actually find performance engineering
is a great way to like basically like
wake yourself up and force yourself to
read stuff because everything is
measurable. So, you can actually like
get become better at agentic
engineering.
>> Because you have feedback. You have like
kind of forces you to learn like okay, I
had all this thing and I thought we had
alignment and I thought we had a good
idea and it didn't actually go any
faster. So, it gives you feedback on how
you are interfacing with the agent in
the like upstream steps.
>> Yeah, and I have like all sorts of
things that I've thrown out because like
I built something and like it was I was
like I was doing a jit stuff over here.
I was trying a few other things.
I don't know. I have some other I
probably they're probably like expired
tasks.
But I have a bunch of our card tasks but
I was I was just trying to make it
faster. And like what I do is I just
like go see this and like okay, is it
faster or not? I think one of them is
like length.
Uh if I length type I Is this it?
No, that's not it. I don't know. I have
something in here where I have like uh
where I was trying to make objects
faster and like you throw away your call
the time and that just teaches you more
about the system under the hood.
Everyone should go try doing some sort
of performance engineering on their own.
I think it's a phenomenal
it's probably the best use of time that
you can have to like really practice
agentic engineering.
>> Yeah, this is cool, man. I
uh
I mean, I remember when we first
one of the first times we hung out you
were just like you should go learn to do
a thing that like seems hard but like
anyone can learn to do anything. And I
think one of your favorite things was
like, "Yeah."
>> You're like 2 years ago I learned to
build a database. I just wanted to learn
everything about databases and on this
caching and spooling and tables and
optimization and queries and all this
stuff. And so I just learned it. And a
lot of people think that like, "Oh, I'll
never be a database engineer." But like
you can go learn anything. And now at
Agents you can actually like just go
read all the source code and understand
all the secret sauce and learn about the
magic tricks that they're doing and what
works and what's not and like where
they're being pragmatic and what the
theory underneath it all is. So, I I
don't know I don't know this is really
cool.
>> There's no freaking way I would have
ever known how like Python does
trampolining to make it work for like
how how does like there's a tool on
Linux called perf?
How does Python, which is an interpreted
language, attach your function calls to
perf? I was like,
that's insane. That was insane to me.
And when I learned I was like, "Oh,
that's so cool."
Um and it just wouldn't have been
possible.
>> Deshawn has a question, how do how do we
start with it? I imagine
how do we start with learning
performance engineering? Do you have any
good like toy problems for people to go
tackle?
>> I I think toy problems actually don't
work for performance engineering. What
you should do is you should take one
part of your system that needs to get
better.
And then what you should first start
doing and like if anyone's building like
an AI agent, an AI agent is a perfect
place to think about performance
engineering.
Because if you think about performance
engineering it an AI agent,
Uh, here's what you can do.
Uh, you can you basically have to think
about it's a black box that you don't
really understand. You have no idea what
the model does or how it does it. You
have cost and latency concerns.
So, what you should you do?
Build a benchmark suite that helps you
profile the workload of your AI agent.
That is a very useful skill set. As soon
as you build a benchmark suite, build
the metrics you want to measure. So,
build how much cost you're taking, build
how many tool call turns you're making,
build how many uh, user turns you're
making.
And you can measure all of these as
performance engineering. You can measure
time if you want.
But you don't have to measure time. Like
if I were Claude code, how do I measure
this? Well,
one easy way to know this is I would
probably track every single time a bash
command calls git commit.
I would track that and I would treat
that as a good signal that things were
successfully done.
And then I'd scour the web for things
that are committed by Claude code and
see if I can associate my tokens with
web commits and see if I can associate
them and now I have a final bridge of
whether or not something was merged. So,
now I have a soft filter on whether or
not something was like good session or
bad session.
And then you can performance engineer
that. Performance engineering isn't just
about making things fast, memory
efficient, or anything else. It's about
this really good feedback loop where you
build data-driven decisions to make your
code base better.
It's like how do you start? You pick a
thing where you're willing to invest
time, money, and resources into
to build a data set. And wherever you're
willing to do that, like
you can performance engineer amazing
things. Yeah, and I want to show this
diagram and see if it pops up.
And if it doesn't, we got 1 minute left.
We'll see if this works. I hate how long
Claude takes. This is like one of my
most annoying things now. I wish we had
a model that was like maybe like 20%
dumber, but like 100% faster.
>> Have you tried Codex 5.5 low?
>> No. I can't. The low The The problem
with lowness is it's not 20% It's not
20% dumber.
>> It's like 40% dumber.
>> Yeah. And like we said like I said like
one wrong thing and everything is a
waste of time.
I think the way I put it is like the
worst things you can do with your tokens
is spend a lot of tokens generating
wrong code.
>> Yeah.
>> thing you can do is spend a lot of
tokens generating the right code.
And the best thing you can do is spend a
few tokens generating the right code.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm sadly stuck in spend a lot of tokens
to generate the right code.
>> Yeah.
Uh well, it's better than generating the
wrong code.
Uh you're also a lot of
>> Good.
>> Your cash is huge here. You have 300,000
tokens. It's probably part of why it's
>> Yeah, but I don't have a choice. Once I
start doing this kind of work in
performance, it just
the context is so important that even if
it's slightly wrong in the older
context, the newer context is like it
needs all that as background so it
doesn't have to rediscover everything.
I actually don't know how I'd be doing
this work on like our profiler without
like a million context million token
context window. It would I think it'd be
>> just need to go back and forth and
maintain that context for a longer time,
and it's better than compacting or
refreshing or whatever.
>> Well, I just I don't even know if I have
the context.
>> You can just open the HTML. You don't
have to wait for it to dump it.
>> Uh that's kind of cool.
>> Um
Oh, we have some iframe caching issues.
So, right right click somewhere and
actually refresh the page and then
you'll see the new one.
Uh so, outside Yeah, just do reload. Uh
I have a ticket to fix this. Uh iframes
are good in some way. Well, it didn't
actually fix it.
That's crazy.
Did it get an error when it wrote the
file?
>> Nope.
>> When you click on the the tool used
Yeah, look it decided it had to read the
file and then rewrite it again.
This is so [__] stupid.
>> Yeah,
uh the way the way we continue cloud
sessions is like it busts the cash and
then so it tries to write the file You
send a message and then it tries to
write the file and then it says, "Oh,
actually
I you haven't read the file yet."
Uh
because there's no way to like if you if
you if you actually pause the session
such that the cloud process like starts
down even if you resume that session it
loses its whole the cache of what files
have been read and not is
uh
in memory. And so you you lose that
cache. So it's going to try to write it
and then it's going to read it and then
it's going to try to write it again.
>> Okay. Well, we'll see this loads.
But hopefully like this gets people an
idea about you go do this. Um any other
questions from anyone while we're here?
>> Josh has a question about the HL public
version. Uh I'm not going to comment on
that other than keep your eyes on
Twitter the next week or two and uh
there will be some fun stuff coming out
as far as uh
what is uh what is uh what is available
to the more general public. It did write
it. So if you right click and reload
again, maybe we can see it.
>> Let's see.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, there you go.
>> We got more boxes.
Yeah. Um
So, actually I can walk through and see
if I can explain some of this.
Um one of the things about like garbage
collected languages you probably want to
have a profile that tells you how
expensive GC is.
Cuz if you don't know how expensive
garbage collection is, what ends up
happening is whatever function ends up
triggering garbage collection looks like
it took a long time. It's one of the
bugs in like a lot of garbage collected
languages like profiling gets messed up.
>> Oh, no.
>> Um
So actually like if you think about how
this is what I saw earlier, like call
gets rewritten to instrumented call.
>> Mhm.
>> does a bunch of stuff and that call is
like half uh like basically one
microsecond
uh or like up to one microsecond um
to just like go back to the user code
before it does this. It's super slow.
Tracing basically has a thread that runs
on a timer and just like profile stuff
onto a ring buffer. So it's quite fast,
but it's a lot slower.
And so you have to make different
trade-offs. And then we had a bunch of
ideas of how we did this.
And uh it's actually really interesting.
I actually will show this to my team. I
think this is going to be highly useful.
Thank you, Dexter.
This diagram is probably helpful.
>> Listen, man. I'm not building a VM
anytime soon, but uh if we can help the
VM builders build better VMs, then uh
then I've done my job.
>> Yeah, this is actually really useful cuz
I can show people the design thoughts
that I had while I went through this.
>> Yeah, so we're we're working on a new
design
discussion skill that is like
specifically like a technical design doc
that is like prompted and steered to do
a lot of this kind of stuff. So, maybe
maybe the next No Vibes Allowed we'll
demo that.
>> Yeah, that'd be great. Uh I can I can
definitely show like how
I can guarantee that like just show
being able to walk through this
step-by-step with my team would be
highly useful.
Just show them like where the memory is
being allocated and what's expensive
about it.